two political news tonight councilman
stavros anthony who represents ward 4
filed for a recount of district c
commission race after
losing to a democrat rather ross miller
this is two days after miller was
declared the winner
that recount begins tomorrow 8 news now
reporter madison kimbrough is live in
the newsroom now with the latest details
for us
madison yes starting tomorrow work
begins for the clark county election
department staff as they will begin
working on a recount that expected to
last all week staffers anthony's
campaign issued a statement on friday
criticizing the commission's
interpretation of the judge's decision
stating that there are still 139 votes
ballots that haven't been counted yet
ross miller a democrat narrowly defeated
anthony
who would have been the only republican
on the commission if he had won
vote totals in the race were 76 586 for
miller
and 76 576 for
anthony separating them by just 10 votes
stavros anthony took to twitter earlier
on thursday to announce
that he will ask for a recount by nevada
law he is required to pay for it but
if he comes out victorious in the
recount he will be reimbursed
so the process like i mentioned is said
to take all week long now according to
clark county
officials staff will start at 5am
tomorrow and work
until 10 p.m throughout the night now
the last day being friday december 11th
so it's going to take
all week long reporting live from the
newsroom madison kimbrough 8 news now